et on va parler de la côte d'ivoire ce
matin en direct d'abidjan avec rodrigue
koné et chercheur à l'institut des
études de sécurité
[Musique]
bonjour audry connaît bonjour merci
beaucoup d'être en direct avec nous ce
matin dans la matinale de rtl france
comment est-ce que le retour de laurent
gbagbo est il perçu à abidjan il aperçut
effectivement comme un événement
important politique c'est une sorte de
retour pour le pays vert au centre à son
histoire descente mais en même temps une
sorte je devrais bientôt relations vers
son futur
une projection vers son futur et donc
tout le monde l'attend avec beaucoup de
joie pour certains avec quelques
inquiétudes pour d'autres mais c'est là
son offre comme une fenêtre
d'opportunité pour parler des questions
importantes rassembler le pays
vous parlez de rassembler le pays c'est
un retour au nom de la réconciliation
nationale qui a été permis par alassane
ouattara l'actuel président dont la
réélection avait pourtant été contestées
dans la rue est ce que ça ne risque pas
de compliquer un peu les choses
je pense que le la scène politique
actuellement croit dû voir avec ce que
vainement c'est que les choses se sont
calmées et on voit un climat beaucoup
plus apaisé de part et d'autre il ya eu
je crois des négociations des dialogues
des gens se sont parlés et chacun dans
le rapport les forces actuellement c'est
l'arène politique sans avoir tout
intérêt à ce que cet événement se
déroule dans une situation beaucoup plus
calme quoique derrière je dirais c'est
par sir officiel d'apaisement il ya des
anges et des intérêts politiques
particuliers qui dans les jours à venir
pourrait nous dire comment va évoluer
effectivement la scène politique le
retour de laurent gbagbo n'est-il pas
perçu comme un symbole finalement de la
résistance face aux ingérences française
comment on se souvient de nicolas
sarkozy qui avait tout fait pour
l'écarter du pouvoir
oui du côté de ses partisans son retour
est carrément vus comme une victoire une
victoire dans une bataille politico
judiciaire et aideront à vous revient
selon ses partisans en je dirais dans
une image de 2,2 conquérant et également
de gagner d'une bataille dans laquelle
il a été non seulement face à son
adversaire et l'historique à la
présidentielle de 2010 mais également à
la coalition de la communauté
internationale qui en son temps avait
soutenu effectivement son adversaire
dans cette bataille militaire
pratiquement et judiciaires ensuite donc
finalement cela interpréter
effectivement du port et de ses
partisans comme un triomphe des avis de
ses adversaires de cette époque là il ya
eu des années de détention préventive à
la haye ce que laurent gbagbo en sort
affaibli et et va-t-il revenir en
politique selon vous oui effectivement
passé dix ans derrière les barreaux on
va dire même si on aboutit à un
acquittement cela laisse quand même des
traces d'une part le rabot à un âge
avancé mais il reste tout de même
combatif et il a lui même dit dans le
dernier était l'une de ses dernières
apparitions publiques qu'il est un
acteur toujours prêts à s'engager dans
l'espace politique ivoirien donc c'est
une période difficile a été difficile
cerveau lui mais il est resté comme atik
toujours dans une posture en tout cas
d'hommes politiques aux petits souhaite
compter encore dans le jeu politique est
ce qu'il ya des
des préparatifs pour pour l'accueillir
laurent gbagbo auquel quel est le
dispositif aujourd'hui en place pour son
retour dans le pays
comme je le disais tout à l'heure il y a
eu je crois un dialogue entre le parti
au pouvoir et son parti politique et sa
famille politique pour préparer je
dirais cet événement donc il y a eu
c'est peut-être quelques restrictions
d'un globalement je pense que l'ensemble
des acteurs sont convenus à ce que c'est
arrivé soit perçu comme un événement
national à la fois du côté de ses
partisans mais également des dispositifs
ont été pris par le parti au pouvoir
pour préparer cet événement et qu'il se
déroule hors je dirais dans un climat
apaisé et pour l'image est ce qu'une
rencontre avec alassane ouattara est
envisageable pour l'instant dans le
programme rien n'est prévu je pense que
il y à des rencontres avec monsieur
bédié qui a été l'un des alliés on va
dire dans cette période de construit
avec monsieur ouattara notamment un
cheval du présent de conan bédié et mais
il n'y a pas de deux rencontres pour
l'instant prévue avec monsieur alassane
ouattara ce qui est un signe qu' il ya
encore quelques défis à relever avant
d'aboutir à un véritable dialogue dont
la nation le peuple ivoirien a fortement
besoin pour savoir ce qui s'est passé
mais aussi pour mettre les hommes
politiques face à leur responsabilité
d'une crise qui a fortement impacté
cette les leaders de premier plan mais
surtout
d'abord les populations ivoiriennes donc
il cherche à comprendre qu'ils cherchent
également à qui ont besoin qu'il y ait
une véritable réconciliation pour que
nos pays se retrouvent l'humain merci
beaucoup
rodrigue connaît de nous avoir livré vos
réflexions en direct ce matin sitôt dans
la matinale merci